gérard larcher bonjour bonjour alors je
rappelle que vous êtes le deuxième
personnage de l'état et que vous êtes un
gaulliste assumer au mois de mai 1968
vous aviez dix neuf ans et vous étiez
engagé depuis 1966 chez les jeunes
gaullistes au moment de ces
mobilisations étudiants qui ont éclaté
en 1968 comment vous percevez ces
événements d'abord je suis engagé c'est
vrai chez les jeunes gaullistes et ma
première réaction est de dire mais
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ces gauchistes
en même temps je perçois qui a là un
mouvement de société et en même temps
c'est le reflet de très nombreux jeunes
engagés engagé politiquement engagé
syndicalement engagé aussi dans la vie
des aumôneries ou spirituelle et cette
réalité là fait que nous sommes assez
nombreux
j'allais dire à avoir une appartenance
politique
en tous les cas des références
politiques j'ai le souvenir de copains
plutôt à gauche d'autres plutôt à droite
de centristes et cet engagement s'est
pas uniquement un ou deux dans une
classe de 1ère ou dans une classe de
terminale et donc pour moi je vis 68
engagé comme jeune gaulliste et comme je
ne lis qu'il entend soutenir l'action du
général de gaulle mais qui en même temps
mesure que cet engagement est aussi le
questionnement le questionnement de la
société de 68 après une période
extraordinaire chat leader de croissance
nous n'avions aucun problème pour
trouver un emploi à la sortie de nos
études nous avions plutôt le sentiment
qu'on vivait de mieux en mieux chaque
année mais en même temps peut-être que
notre génération avait aussi
d'interrogations
quelle sera ma place dans les décisions
de la société
or je rappelle que le général de gaulle
est au pouvoir depuis dix ans puisqu'il
accède au pouvoir en
958 vous dit qu'il y avait un certain
questionnement sur quoi ça repose et
c'est d'abord le général de gaulle chez
c'est pas dix ans de pouvoir c'est une
épopée
c'est dans l'imaginaire d'un jeune que
moi qui a va avoir dix neuf ans c'est
l'homme qui a redonné à la france son
honneur je vis en normandie dans des
villes qui sont reconstruction après les
bombardements et ça m'a marqué moi même
je suis un enfant qui se voit intégrer
une maison reconstruite après les
bombardements de maison qui est affecté
à ses parents et donc cette maison
quelque part les le symbole du renouveau
de notre pays et on le doit au général
de gaulle alors bien sûr il ya dix ans
de cinquième république
on a presque oublié que la génération
précédente elle partait faire la guerre
en algérie
on a le sentiment d'entrer dans une
société de consommation et en même temps
la préoccupation de pas simplement des
consommateurs on a me semble-t-il le
désir ou qu'on soit sur les chevaux
politique ou syndical on a envie d'être
acteurs et quand vous voyez que le
gouvernement ordonne peut-être une
répression sur ces jeunes qui
manifestent qui ont quasiment votre âge
quelle réaction vous avez d'abord les
jeunes ils vont pas j'allais dire à
moitié moi j'ai des souvenirs très
précis puisque je suis en classe
préparatoire vétérinaire voilà que des
jeunes veulent m'empêcher de passer le
concours vétérinaire mais je vous cache
pas j'ai pas fait le coup de poing mais
quand même pas loin en même temps
j'étais engagé puisque je représentais
les classes préparatoires au conseil
d'administration voyez je n'étais pas
passifs et le jeune engagé que je suis
décidé on a le droit de passer ses
examens décide d'aller dialoguer
dialoguer c'est amour atténuée après
cinq décennies d'aller débattre avec un
certain nombre de ces jeunes
en même temps nous assistons à la
paralysie progressive du pays parce que
il ya toute la dimension ce alliance
sociale et cette dimension sociale en
même temps la répression
mai 68 il n'y a pas un seul mort à
méditer sur la manière dont d'ailleurs
le pouvoir a conduit alors qu'il y avait
des manifestations et une manifestation
et 2 millions de manifestants
jal et envir justement parce que vous
parlez du mouvement social derrière
c'est les ouvriers qui qui vont
manifester vers le 13 mai il commence à
dessiner des à montrer leurs
revendications salariales notamment
quel regard vous portiez à 7 à ce moment
là sur la politique notamment économique
menée par le gouvernement rapide ou nous
sommes dans le plein emploi mais y'a
désir de modernisation je crois des
relations sociales
il ya un désir de mieux partager les
fruits du développement
d'ailleurs c'est une partie du projet du
général de gaulle qui n'a jamais
vraiment aboutie qui et l'intéressement
et la participation dans le projet
gaulliste qui vaut d'ailleurs mon
engagement
comme gaulliste social c'est de dire il
y a qu une seule économie qui fonctionne
on lui donne pas encore ce nom à ce
moment là c'est l'économie de marché
l'économie libérale mais elle doit être
tempérée tempéré à la fois par une
politique sociale mais aussi par la
participation de chacun au développement
de son entreprise son activité et au
partage des fruits de la croissance
et ça je le comprends c'est bien et il
faut le dire le président pompidou pour
lequel j'ai un immense respect il n'est
pas très favorable à l'intéressement et
à la participation est d'ailleurs les
jeunes gaullistes l'union des jeunes
pour le progrès parce que c'est autour
de cette sensibilité là que nous nous
retrouvons content que nous soyons carte
ou pas en kart c'est pas le sujet
ils ont envie d'aller plus loin dans la
dimension sociale à la fois ils
s'opposent aux étudiants gaucho souvenez
vous il était bao certains étaient
encore nés aux staliniens et pour nous
c'était inacceptable
d'autres étaient ce qu'on qualifiait d
extrême droite mais étaient dans une
nostalgie de l'algérie française
je dis ça parce que au classement
automatiquement extrême droite c c'était
une nostalgie et nous ont dit le général
de gaulle lac bien conduit la
décolonisation il a redonné l'honneur à
notre pays
il a proposé le développement et c'est
vrai que la société s'interroge un an
avant le général de gaulle accepte la
proposition de loi de lucien de hoerdt
la régulation savez lucien neuwirth j'ai
l'honneur ou siéger avec lui bien après
on l'appelait le père la pilule mais
c'est une révolution culturelle
il faut bien le mesurer et le général de
gaulle l'a acceptée tu es sans doute pas
dans sa pensée de base et on sent une
société qui veut évoluer